I just came back from Jeju Island, and wow,...
...is that place amazing or what!
But, can I ask you a quick question on why more Korean people tend to travel overseas...
...when they can simply fly to Jeju Island or anywhere within Korea to enjoy a nice vacation?
I think it's because most of them want to experience cultural...
...and atmospheric differences outside of Korea.
I personally prefer to travel abroad,...
...but not like places that are far away from Korea.
I like traveling to neighboring countries like China, Thailand, Japan or Hong Kong.
Even in Japan, you will experience a huge difference in culture compared to Korea.
Since it doesn't cost that much,...
...I go to those other Asian countries twice a year...
...during the summer and winter.
Let's hear what you have on your mind.
I love traveling.
In fact, I don't mind traveling nationally or internationally as long as I can afford it.
Well, in fact, after traveling to some European countries,...
...I would say that traveling in Europe is the best, again, if I can afford it.
Europe? How nice!
I've never been to Europe before.
I just saw the beautiful pictures of European countries like France, Italy and Spain.
I see a lot of Koreans also go to Europe for their vacation.
Okay, I'm going to take a trip to Europe this summer...
...after I've earned some money in a part-time job.